boys up guys today we're going to do the
Lavoie challenge welcome everyone to the
why YouTube favorites show everybody
where I review the memes and you guys
post them
you are welcome by the way the most
glorious honor in the whole platform of
YouTube's Internet is to have your meme
appear on the la BISE subreddit if you
end up in this video feel free to retire
leave your entries in the pros Hey look
everybody morale initi memes that's not
out late already at all
Oh copy strike that's that's pretty good
congratulations her he's probably
thinking about another woman PIM
why is pew nurse called pew news if it's
hosted by Gloria Borger China may be
using si to hide its submarines foods
channel content or use original content
it is original content it has my face is
I'm not original enough this is America
it must be to must be steaming right now
that's right vice verse feed to my
favorite news site must be to the
definite guide to enlightening
information yes of course
the truth and nothing but the truth it's
this purity I don't know if you guys saw
this there was a nurse there was an
article from Vancouver that posted day I
went to the suicide fordist
a consider P defy the world's most
subscribed youtuber who earlier this
year visited yeah
then suicide for it I was ki Hara and
posted footage of a man who died by
source how could he do that I hate patty
pie when will he learn he never learns
illinit e I'm 10 person stop okay guys I
see I see like everyone is still trying
to get like attention from her just we
both clearly moved on like there's no
reason to keep on meaning it although it
was very funny did you do it yes at and
what did it cost 399 everybody have I
told you about my chick where did he go
where did he go stay with Thanos stick
right chair official crush of PD PI fan
base kind of weird for me to have a
crush I'm only 9 after all that's right
army of nine-year-olds hurray ABCD in
the future we're gonna need
hieroglyphics to understand this meme
it's so weird running from thinners
fighting Sanders find a weapon to help
Anna's turning Sanders into a meme and
then killing him with me hey look
someone fixed it you made it right :
twit start calling them twitch guys
please stop so I have to meme correction
I decided to buy the rights well done
well done congratulations eating a
picture of who defy every day until II
wait he's still going he's still going
at 399 at 399 mark my words okay maybe a
hundred how about that if you can make
200 I don't know I'm not even gonna say
what is channel name is cuz YouTube this
is gonna ban him again top g-dub suing
fortnight for copyright infringement
can we copies can we copy shrek for at
night health minister of Belgium
illusion hundred I would say illusion
zero that was a fat joke everybody very
subtle so it's okay Christian channel
YouTube watch through the video they're
like wait a minute
instead ah and it keeps going
congratulations everyone now I'm
actually starting to think that you are
actually nine years old like Jesus
Christ there you go thank you for
correcting a meme correction well done
everybody
yeah this is what it's getting now like
come on this subreddit is about me okay
stop it oh my god please what the heck
don't worry girl you are now under
protected by the nine year old army
because you supported our kid yeah well
what about the king what about me
upload if you want is to change the name
of the fan base from squad fam to nine
year old it's already happened it's
inevitable
[Music]
we are now entering the final page of
memes hooray
maybe we can get some actually decent
ones that actually makes me feel good
that makes me Scott
E ABCD alphabet ins great great this
made it to the front page everybody
congratulations if women rule the world
said my wife there would be no world
that's true I replied wars requires
strategy and logic write an article
about this this is terrible this is so
this is so offensive not just for me but
for when all women are I am beauty pie
Gloria Borger no she did not tweet that
she did not know there's no way she
would mean that too serious oh man maybe
one day Jesus Christ do you just want to
take over my channel well guys it would
seem that I have been replaced the
nine-year-olds have voted and I will no
longer be doing this channel thank you
guys it's been real it's been a good
eight years actually you know what it's
been kinda mediocre to say the least
good bye everybody it's been great
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys know that you're literally that
mean where someone said the teenager
someone's a girl being moderately nice
to me
that's what's happening here right okay
someone at my graduation has this cap is
that real that's not real beauty carpet
I heard you agree that yes I kind of
wore Peter Piper to New Zealand it's at
an actual Brook from the audience to
keep you up-to-date
Who am I reading that please Brooklyn
thanks Jeremy you and I only just met so
need to wait it out before we call each
other just friends really how long
well we'll tell you after the break
please what is this show it looks like a
newest show are we infiltrating the
system well done
proud of you white tiger five times zero
beautiful time merch awkward handshake
Congrats you're a real fan nine years
old thanks
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yes it's in our DNA
okay we don't do handshakes on this
channel hey look at that everybody
fantastic it's just become that the ally
and the enemy of the channel basically
Hey look another one another one upload
if you won't look another what the hell
Jesus Christ petition for my Santa hos
beauties
that's right mindset is queen everybody
Ronnie what did you do boy if you love
memes and you know if I'm your handsome
hey you kill me and you know it clap
your hands
and if you kill means and you can avenge
my ear heads of our time grande you're
the best of course it can I got a really
bad dirt bag accident broke basically
everything in my chest colt collapse my
right lung was bleeding my lungs was
bleeding into my lungs I couldn't move
my right arm the stupid outfit and me
was all I could think of you guys are
weird
you guys are 9 year old I don't know
what has to say at this point but
honestly that's hilarious
madam x 1 9 9 9 I hope you get a good
recovery and thanks for keeping the
memes alive if you guys want to keep the
memes alive
check out subreddit check out subreddit
how is English check out subreddit down
below and the post it's something
interesting something nice something
cool I am ball right everybody action
mad alright so like I said I'm not gonna
do this channel anymore there's really
no point clearly I've been replaced so
take it sky thank you
well hello there
it's Kyle oh and from now on I'm taking
over this channel thanks to 9 year olds
so don't forget to hit that like button
three times
subscribe to this awesome child and I
will see you tomorrow